From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Long ago, when our radio show was first on the air, we tried an experiment, two experiments, actually. We did two of our shows onstage in Chicago within six months of each other. In the first, at this small club called the Lunar Cabaret, we had a kind of open mic, where people came onstage and they read letters, letters that they'd received, letters that they'd written, letters that they'd found.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。很久以前，当我们的广播节目刚开播时，我们做了一个实验，其实是两个实验。我们在六个月内先后在芝加哥举办了两场现场节目。第一场在一家名为“月球歌舞厅”的小俱乐部，我们设置了一种类似开放麦的环节，人们上台朗读信件，读他们收到的信、写的信，或是捡到的信。
The second show, at the Museum of Contemporary Art, was all about this new phenomenon called the internet. This was 1997, and most people were still just discovering the internet. And we invited our listeners to come on and tell us stories about things that were happening on the web that never would have happened anywhere else.
第二场节目是在当代艺术博物馆举办的，主题是当时一个叫“互联网”的新事物。那是1997年，大多数人还处于刚刚发现互联网的阶段。我们邀请听众上台讲述那些发生在网络上，而且绝不可能在其他地方发生的奇闻轶事。
Today on our radio show, we're going to go back to those two shows. They're like little time capsules, those shows. The internet stuff, which is going to be the second half of today's program, it just seems so quaint that we were asking ourselves, how big is this internet thing going to be? Is it really going to change things? And the letters that people read onstage that we're going to play in the first half of  the show, even that feels like it's from a completely other time. Like, today, who writes letters? When do you write a letter except for a thank you note or a letter to get a job? Even soldiers in Iraq, when they write home to their families, they use email.
今天我们的广播节目将重温那两场演出。那些节目就像小小的时光胶囊。关于互联网的内容，也就是今天节目的下半部分，我们当时问自己“互联网到底会有多大？”“它真的会改变一切吗？”这种想法现在看来真是古朴得可爱。而在上半部分中，人们在台上朗读的那些信件，读起来也仿佛来自另一个时代。比如，现在还有谁会写信呢？除了感谢卡或是求职信，你什么时候会写信？即使是驻伊拉克的士兵，给家里写信时用的也是电子邮件。
My co-host for both of these old shows was a Chicago playwright named David Hauptschein. David had been hosting and organizing events like this around Chicago where he would have people come onstage and read letters. So let's go back in time to 1996 and 1997.
那两场老节目的联合主持人是一位名叫大卫·豪普沙因的芝加哥剧作家。大卫当时就在芝加哥各地组织这类活动，请人们上台读信。那么，让我们回到1996年和1997年吧。
All right, you see this egg timer here? This egg timer will get you off the stage after five minutes. When you hear [BELL RING] that, you must stop. If you're really nervous, I have this little elephant for people to hold, in case they're really--
好了，看到这个计时器了吗？这个计时器能让你在五分钟后离开舞台。当你听到（铃声）那个声音时，你必须停下来。如果你真的很紧张，我这儿有个小象玩偶可以让你拿着，以防你……
He's holding up a--
他举起了一个……
Oh, it's a rhino. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
哦，那是只犀牛。抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。
You're holding up about a six-inch long, gray rhinoceros, fluffy rhinoceros.
你手里拿的是一只大约六英寸长、灰色的毛绒犀牛。
So I will leave this up here on the podium. So if anyone gets really tense, just hang on to this.
那我就把它留在讲台上。所以，如果谁觉得特别紧张，就抓着它。
I hold in my hand a bowl, a silver bowl full of pieces of paper on which members of our audience here have written their names.
我手里拿着一个碗，一个银色的碗，里面装满了观众写下他们名字的纸条。
Please pick the first name, Ira.
请抽第一个名字，艾拉。
John Beaderman, come on up.
约翰·比德曼，上来吧。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
OK, I'll read you a couple things from Carolyn. Hiya, hun. What are you up to? I'm listening to Motley Crue, Shout at the Devil. That's a pretty kick-ass tape. It's Joe's, but it's still a kick-ass tape, and Vince Neil is such a fox. I'd love to go backstage at a Crue concert. I'd be in total heaven, because I know what I'd do, and I'll bet you do too. Like my green marker? I think it's cool. Explain this to me. Something fishy's going on. What? I don't know. But you're acting fishy, so don't lie, and it's nothing I did.
好的，我来给你读两段卡罗琳写的东西。嘿，亲爱的。你在干嘛？我正在听克鲁小丑乐队的《向恶魔呐喊》。那磁带真是酷毙了。那是乔的，但依然很棒，文斯·尼尔真是个万人迷。我真想去克鲁小丑演唱会的后台。我会完全陷入天堂，因为我知道我会做什么，我敢打赌你也知道。喜欢我的绿色记号笔吗？我觉得很酷。给我解释一下这个。有什么猫腻在发生。什么？我不知道。但你的行为很可疑，所以别撒谎，这不是我做的。
I don't act any different than before we did it. Are you trying to say that I'm acting different, or I'm slightly more insane than unusual? Is that what you mean? I'm acting differently? If that's what you mean, how? I just heard Judas Priest [? talking to ?] Dio. That's pretty kick-ass. Why did Chris ask for me today? And why did you guys hang up on me? That's pretty ignorant, not to mention immature and rude.
我的行为和我们做那事之前没什么不同。你是想说我的行为变了，还是说我比平时更疯狂了一点？你是这个意思吗？我的行为变了吗？如果是这样，怎么变的？我刚听到犹大圣徒乐队在和迪奥聊天。那真是太酷了。为什么克里斯今天问起我？你们为什么要挂我电话？这真是无知，更别提既幼稚又不礼貌了。
I'm listening to Motley Crue, "Bastard" again, so they are so cool. I haven't decided if I like Crue or Maiden better yet, but they're both totally kick-ass. God, is this note [BLEEP] dumb. It's 7:30 and I want it to be 8:30 because then I can listen to RPM, Real Precious Metal 103.1. 831-1031. Kick ass! "Helter skelter, you may be a lover but you ain't no dancer, helter skelter."
我正在听克鲁小丑乐队的《混蛋》，它们真是太酷了。我还没决定是更喜欢克鲁小丑还是铁娘子乐队，但它们都酷毙了。天哪，这张字条真是（消音）蠢透了。现在是七点半，我希望是八点半，那样我就能听RPM，真正的金属之声103.1。831-1031。酷毙了！“混乱，你可能是个恋人，但你不是个舞者，混乱。”
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
OK, Ira.
好的，艾拉。
Next reader, Neal Pollack.
下一位朗读者，尼尔·波拉克。
Hi. I wrote-- can I hold this?
嗨。我写了……我可以拿着这个吗？
Please do.
请便。
Neal is holding the rhinoceros.
尼尔拿着那只犀牛。
I wrote these letters soon after I graduated from college. And I like to turn back to them every now and then to remind myself what an idiot I was. I believed at the time that I could get any job I wanted anywhere at any point. And these letters, I think, are indicative.
我写这些信是在我大学毕业后不久。我喜欢不时地回头读读它们，好提醒自己当初有多蠢。我当时坚信我随时随地都能得到任何我想要的工作。我想，这些信就是证据。
Here's one I wrote to Tina Brown, who was then the editor of Vanity Fair magazine. Dear Ms. Brown, I'll cut to the quick. [LAUGHTER] I would like to work for The New Yorker , and I imagine, with the big changeover, you may need lots of editorial help. So I'm throwing my hat into the ring and asking you to consider hiring me as an editorial assistant for your new project.
这是我写给蒂娜·布朗的一封，她当时是《名利场》杂志的主编。亲爱的布朗女士，我长话短说。（笑声）我想为《纽约客》工作，我想随着这次大的变动，你们可能需要很多编辑方面的帮助。所以我毛遂自荐，希望你能考虑雇我担任你们新项目的编辑助理。
I've been precociously reading The New Yorker for some time now. Most of the writers I respect most, living and dead, have written for your magazine at some time. I'm willing to cut my journalistic and literary teeth elsewhere if I can't get a job at The New Yorker , but I am determined not to end up anywhere else. The resume I've enclosed doesn't indicate this, but I've been working as a freelance writer since graduating two months ago. [LAUGHTER]
我已经早慧地阅读《纽约客》很久了。我尊敬的多数作家，无论生前死后，都曾为你们杂志写过文章。如果我不能在《纽约客》得到一份工作，我愿意在别处磨练我的新闻和文学功底，但我决心不去其他任何地方。我附上的简历没写出来，但我从两个月前毕业起就一直在做自由撰稿人。（笑声）
I've been doing pretty well, but I'm still waiting for the big score. Maybe you could help. I strongly encourage you to take a chance on me, but if I don't suit your needs at this time, thank you for reviewing my application. I look forward to hearing from you. [APPLAUSE]
我干得还不错，但还在等待一个大机会。也许你能帮上忙。我强烈建议你给我一个机会，但如果此时不符合你的需求，谢谢你审阅我的申请。期待你的回复。（掌声）
About six months later, I hadn't yet heard from Tina Brown. So I turned my gaze elsewhere. Here's one I wrote to Strobe Talbott, who at the time was an editor-at-large at Time Magazine , and now, as you may or may not know, is a Deputy to the Secretary of State in the Clinton administration. So here's what I wrote to Strobe.
大约六个月后，我还没收到蒂娜·布朗的回信。所以我把目光转向了别处。这是我写给斯特罗布·塔尔博特的，他当时是《时代》杂志的特约编辑，现在，不管你知不知道，他是克林顿政府的副国务卿。这就是我写给斯特罗布的内容。
Dear Mr. Talbott, I'm a damn good editor. I'm young and gutsy as a marine in combat. My terse, tough prose style would make Raymond Chandler weep. Somewhere, somehow, the grapevine told me that you're starting a magazine called Globe Review . Said vine also let me know that the staff will be small, which means you're not hiring too many people. [LAUGHTER]
亲爱的塔尔博特先生，我是一名出色的编辑。我年轻，像作战的海军陆战队员一样有胆识。我简练、强硬的文风会让雷蒙德·钱德勒落泪。不知何故，小道消息告诉我，你正在创办一本叫《环球评论》的杂志。该消息还让我知道，员工编制会很小，这意味着你不会雇佣太多人。（笑声）
Being low man on the totem pole is fine with me. Your magazine sounds original, smart, and progressive, sophisticated but not shallow. Of course, I'm just guessing. Can you go global without me? I think so. Should you? I think not. Or at least hope not. I'll do good work as an assistant editor, copy editor, or researcher.
在等级制度的最底层对我来说没问题。你的杂志听起来原创、聪明、进步、成熟但不浅薄。当然，我只是在猜测。没有我，你能走向全球吗？我想可以。你应该这样做吗？我认为不应该。或者至少希望不要。无论作为助理编辑、校对还是研究员，我都能胜任。
I'll be in New York City from November 11 through 17. If you'd like to interview me, you can contact me at the Chicago address on my resume until then. Thank you for reviewing my application, and I look forward to seeing the magazine, whether I'm part of it or not. [APPLAUSE]
我将于11月11日到17日在纽约市。如果你想面试我，在此之前你可以通过我简历上的芝加哥地址联系我。谢谢你审阅我的申请，无论我是否参与其中，我都期待看到这本杂志。（掌声）
Next reader, Jenny Magnus.
下一位朗读者，珍妮·马格努斯。
All right, this is a letter that I received. It's addressed to me. So my name is Jenny Magnus. And on the envelope it says, "Lessons for Advanced Beginners." And then on the back, it says, "burn after reading."
好的，这是一封我收到的信。是写给我的。我叫珍妮·马格努斯。信封上写着“高级初学者课程”。背面写着“阅后即焚”。
Dear Ms. Magnus, I almost fell off my chair when, during one of your pieces, you implied that you are, quote, "a really good artist." After sitting there listening to you chant "mama, mama, mama, mama, mama," which you got from Janov's book Primal Scream-- I shop through paperbacks at thrift stores, too-- then hearing you chant "give it to me, give it to me, give it to me, give it to me, give it to me," I sat there wondering just how conventional some pretentious chick dressed in black can be.
亲爱的马格努斯女士，当你在某件作品中暗示自己是“一个非常好的艺术家”时，我差点从椅子上摔下来。看着你坐在那里一遍遍吟唱着从贾诺夫的《原始呐喊》书里学来的“妈妈，妈妈，妈妈，妈妈，妈妈”——我在旧货店买平装书也是这样——然后听你吟唱“给我，给我，给我，给我，给我”，我坐在那里心想，一个穿着黑衣、装腔作势的女孩到底能有多世俗。
I, by the way, use "chick" lightly, since you are not very feminine. In fact, you are nothing but a contrived, self-deceiving, selfish, not overly bright, mediocre joke. You might be able to fool the poseurs who hang around Urbis Orbis flattering your brother pretending to know, but not me, babe. Not me, babe. I use "babe" lightly. You are not a babe. You have-- [LAUGHTER] You have no sensuality, no charm, no looks, et cetera.
顺便说一句，我用“女孩”这个词很轻，因为你一点也不女性化。事实上，你只是一个矫揉造作、自欺欺人、自私、不太聪明、平庸的笑话。你也许能骗过那些在乌比斯·奥比斯附近游荡、恭维你兄弟、假装懂行的装逼犯，但骗不了我，宝贝。骗不了我，宝贝。我用“宝贝”这个词很轻。你不是个宝贝。你——（笑声）你没有性感，没有魅力，没有长相，等等。
Without affectation, without deliberately taking steps to appear avant, where would you be? Nothing comes naturally to you, does it? You really have to steal and grub and labor. In fact, you are perusing this letter for material right now, I bet. [LAUGHTER]
如果没有这些做作，如果没有刻意地去装前卫，你会在哪里？没有什么东西是自然而然产生的，对吧？你真的必须去窃取、去贪婪、去劳作。事实上，我敢打赌你现在就在翻这封信找素材。（笑声）
I realized how repressed and affected you are during "Loser's Alias." And thank God for the fire which started, or you'd probably still be on the floor reciting your brother's tripe. You are just too, too uptight, baby. You think you can act uninhibited, but why do you want to? Is it that important to you that you seem to yourself and others as if you are special?
在《失败者的化名》那场演出中，我意识到你是多么压抑和做作。感谢上帝发生了那场火灾，否则你可能还在地板上背诵你兄弟的废话。你太紧绷了，宝贝。你以为你可以表现得无拘无束，但你为什么要这么做呢？让你自己和别人觉得你很特别就那么重要吗？
You are quite interesting, the only person with absolutely no substance I've ever met. How did you get so [BLEEP]? Give up art. You're no good at it, anyway. And save your [BLEEP] ass. Sincerely, Mason 32 Degrees. PS, well, I've done my good deed for tonight. [APPLAUSE]
你真是有趣，是我见过的唯一一个完全没有内涵的人。你是怎么变得这么（消音）的？放弃艺术吧。反正你不擅长。并且省省你那（消音）屁股吧。真诚地，梅森32度。附言，好吧，我今晚做了件好事。（掌声）
Our next reader, pulled from our bowl of readers, Adam Davidson. [APPLAUSE]
下一位朗读者，从我们的碗里抽出来的，亚当·戴维森。（掌声）
OK. This is age 16. Dear Adam, I can lose my guard best when I write. No wonder I scared off S with my letter. Speaking of which, I didn't hear from him. You see, how can I ever think of hurting you like that? Let's say something starts between us. What about S? I may not like him, but maybe I do.
好的。这是16岁时写的。亲爱的亚当，当我写作时，我最容易放下戒备。难怪我用那封信吓跑了S。说到这个，我没收到他的回音。你看，我怎么会想那样伤害你呢？假设我们之间开始了一些什么。那S怎么办？我可能不喜欢他，但也可能喜欢。
Also, what if I'm just on the rebound from Dave? Not that I didn't like you before-- maybe I'm just free to say it now-- but I might be exaggerating it because I'm feeling a loss. Maybe we're confusing a really good friendship for love, et cetera. You know the deal.
另外，如果我只是在大卫之后寻求安慰呢？并不是说我以前不喜欢你——也许我只是现在才有勇气说出来——但我可能是在夸大它，因为我感到一种失落。也许我们把非常好的友谊误认为是爱情，等等。你懂的。
Also, let's say we do have sex. It'll be a bigger deal for you. Not that I won't take it seriously. I have seriously thought about it. But it's a big responsibility to put on me, your first time, et cetera. Now who's babbling? Anyway, [LAUGHTER] I think you're a wonderful person and friend, and the last thing I want to do is screw that up.
而且，假设我们真的发生了性关系。这对你来说会是件大事。并不是说我不严肃对待。我已经认真考虑过了。但这对我来说责任太重，这是你的第一次，等等。现在是谁在胡言乱语？不管怎样，（笑声）我觉得你是一个很棒的人和朋友，我最不想做的就是搞砸这一切。
Maybe we should just see, trial-run, if making out agrees with us. You never know, we might decide it doesn't feel right and keep things status quo. But we might end up getting it on every day. Excuse the vulgar language. As that guy in English class would say, "there is no pretty way to look at sex."
也许我们应该先试试，试验一下，看看亲热是否适合我们。谁知道呢，也许我们可能会觉得感觉不对，然后保持现状。但也可能我们最终会每天都腻在一起。请原谅粗俗的语言。正如英语课上那个家伙说的，“看待性没有优雅的方式。”
Anyway, I love you, but I'm not sure what kind of love. Love, K. Geez, I don't even know what attracts me to you. You're so [BLEEP] perfect I guess.
不管怎样，我爱你，但我不知道是哪种爱。爱你的，K。天哪，我甚至不知道是什么吸引我喜欢你。我想你真是（消音）完美。
Then supplemental letter-- supplementary letter. Will things be the same once the sexual tension is gone? I think that's half the fun. It's what has kept Moonlighting on the air. Will we still be able to joke about getting married, et cetera, without feeling uncomfortable? Confusion, is there an S in confusion? I'm even mixed up about that.
然后是补充信——补充信。一旦性张力消失，一切还会一样吗？我想那才是乐趣的一半。正是这一点让《蓝色月光》一直播下去。我们还能开玩笑说结婚之类的事吗？而不会感到尴尬？困惑，困惑里有S吗？连这个问题都让我很困惑。
We went out after that for a year. [APPLAUSE]
那之后我们交往了一年。（掌声）
Andrew Fenchel?
安德鲁·芬切尔？
OK, I found this letter in the street in my neighborhood. I think it won't really need any other introduction, except that where the letter-writer refers to Vienna, I think it's safe to assume that that's not Austria. OK.
好的，我在社区街上捡到了这封信。我想除了说明写信人提到的“维也纳”大概不是指奥地利之外，不需要任何介绍。好了。
Time, 10:00 PM. June 10, '96. Dear Carla, what's up, babe? How are you doing? Fine, I hope. Well, I'm in Vienna. But I didn't forget to write.
时间，晚上10点。1996年6月10日。亲爱的卡拉，怎么了，宝贝？你还好吗？希望你很好。嗯，我在维也纳。但我没忘记给你写信。
Baby, I miss you. I can't wait to see you. I've been thinking about you all the time, and I can't stop. I got into a fight in here with a king, and for that I got two weeks in the hole. Baby, I hope you're not talking to someone else. I've been waiting for your letters, but I haven't received any yet. What's up with that?
宝贝，我想你。我等不及要见你了。我一直想着你，停不下来。我和一个国王打了一架，因此我被关了两周禁闭。宝贝，希望你没有和别人说话。我一直在等你的信，但还没收到。怎么回事？
Carla, I feel that you don't love me anymore. Baby, I love you more than what you could ever know. I miss making love to you, kissing you. Please send me some pictures of you. When I get out of here, I'm going to get a job. I'll even quit gang-banging if you show me you love me.
卡拉，我觉得你不再爱我了。宝贝，我爱你胜过你能想象的任何程度。我想念和你做爱，亲吻你。请寄给我一些你的照片。我出去后，会找份工作。如果你表现出爱我，我甚至会退出帮派。
Carla, what do you mean when you say you went from 100% to 50%? I don't understand. I haven't been cheating on you, and I'll be with you all the time when I get out. Carla, I care about you a lot. You just don't know.
卡拉，你说从100%变成50%是什么意思？我不明白。我没有背叛你，我出去后会一直陪着你。卡拉，我非常在乎你。你只是不知道。
Why is your mom going to kick you out? What have you done? Please don't lie to me. Are you [BLEEP] around with someone else, staying out late? What is it? I've got the feeling you are seeing someone else, but I guess I can't trip, so long as when I get out, you come back to me.
你妈妈为什么要把你赶出去？你做了什么？请别对我说谎。你是不是在和别人（消音），还在外面待到很晚？怎么了？我有种感觉你在和别人约会，但我猜我不能抱怨，只要我出去时你回到我身边就行。
What do you mean that you love me and good luck in life? [LAUGHTER] I get the first part but not the second. [LAUGHTER] [APPLAUSE] Are you breaking up with me? Are you going away from me? Whatever you do, wherever you go, you'll always be in my heart, Carla. Believe that.
你说你爱我，祝我生活顺利是什么意思？（笑声）前半部分我懂，后半部分我不懂。（笑声）（掌声）你要和我分手吗？你要离开我吗？无论你做什么，无论你去哪，你永远在我心中，卡拉。相信这一点。
I know you think I don't love you anymore, but you're wrong, babe. I said it before and I'll say it again, I love you Carla. [APPLAUSE]
我知道你觉得我不再爱你了，但你错了，宝贝。我说过，我会再说一遍，我爱你，卡拉。（掌声）
[MUSIC - "I GOT A LETTER FROM MY BABY" BY ELMORE JAMES]
（音乐——埃尔莫尔·詹姆斯的《我收到我宝贝的信》）
Coming up, a guy offers a girl a late night tour of Microsoft, and this actually makes him seem hot. That, and other hard-to-believe tales from the early days of the internet, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
即将播出，一个家伙给女孩提供了一次深夜参观微软的机会，这竟然让他看起来很迷人。这，以及其他关于互联网早期阶段难以置信的故事，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, we're revisiting two live shows that we did in 1996 and '97, onstage in Chicago. In one show, listeners brought letters and read them onstage. And now we turn to the other show from back then. Back then, the internet was still new to most of us. And so we decided we were going to do a show where we would try to figure out what was happening on the internet, especially if things were happening on the internet that would never happen anyplace else.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚调过来，我们正在重温我们在1996年和1997年在芝加哥舞台上做的两场现场节目。在一场节目中，听众带信来并在台上朗读。现在我们转向那时的另一场节目。那时，互联网对我们大多数人来说还是很新的事物。所以我们决定做一个节目，试图弄清楚互联网上正在发生什么，特别是如果网上发生了一些在其他任何地方都不会发生的事情。
And to answer that question, we advertised in cities around the country, inviting people to send us their stories about life on the internet. Some of these people I interviewed, and then others just showed up at the theater, at the Museum of Contemporary Art in Chicago, the night we did the show. And they came up to the mic, and they read from emails or web pages.
为了回答这个问题，我们在全国各地的城市做了广告，邀请人们把他们关于互联网生活的故事发给我们。有些人我采访过，另一些人则是在我们演出当晚直接出现在芝加哥当代艺术博物馆的剧院里。他们走上麦克风，朗读电子邮件或网页上的内容。
And I have to say, listening to this show, it's almost adorably quaint, the entire mission of this show. It's almost embarrassing, actually, to hear me and other people trying to think through this question, like, what is this internet? What is new about the internet? You'll hear there is a point where I'm talking to a woman who's looking through the websites of complete strangers. And it's like, can you believe it? She's looking through the websites of complete strangers.
我不得不说，听这场节目，整个节目的使命几乎可爱得古朴。事实上，听我和其他人试图思考这个问题，比如“什么是互联网？”“互联网有什么新奇的？”甚至让人感到尴尬。你会听到我当时和一位正在浏览完全陌生人网站的女士交谈。就像是，“你能相信吗？她在浏览完全陌生人的网站。”
And then she has this experience, which now is incredibly common, where she meets in person somebody who she first met on the internet. And we're all talking about it like, can you believe that such a thing can happen in this world that we live in? You'll hear. It's really interesting. It's like a historic document. So without further ado, let us turn on the time machine and go back to 1997. [APPLAUSE]
然后她有了这种现在非常普遍的经历，就是见到了她在网上认识的人。我们都在讨论它，好像，“你能相信在我们生活的这个世界里竟然会发生这样的事吗？”你会听到的。这真的很有趣。它就像一份历史文献。所以不再多说，让我们打开时光机回到1997年吧。（掌声）
So Mary is 19 years old, an English major at the University of Washington. And one day, she's cruising the net, visiting the home pages of complete strangers.
玛丽今年19岁，是华盛顿大学的英语专业学生。有一天，她在网上冲浪，访问完全陌生人的主页。
And I came across this site that I thought was amazing. It was the most cutting-edge, thought-provoking site I had ever seen. And so I was examining it, checking it out, and I realized that this guy was my age, and he worked at Microsoft. And that just blew me away. Because I'm a student, I can barely afford coffee in the morning. And here, this guy worked at Microsoft.
我偶然发现了一个网站，我觉得太棒了。这是我见过最尖端、最发人深省的网站。所以我仔细检查，查看它，我意识到这个家伙和我同岁，而且他在微软工作。这让我大吃一惊。因为我是学生，早上连咖啡都喝不起。而在这里，这家伙在微软工作。
I ended up emailing him just to tell him how much I liked his site and how amazing I thought it was. And he wrote back. And that went on for about four or five days. We just kept writing back and forth. Really personal stuff, too, not just computer geek stuff.
我最终给他发了电子邮件，只是告诉他我有多喜欢他的网站，以及我觉得它有多棒。他回信了。这种情况持续了四五天。我们不断地写回信。非常私人的东西，不仅仅是电脑极客的东西。
What is the brave new world of the internet? You can meet a stranger and get to know them intimately, much faster on the net than you can anywhere else. But for a week, Mary and this guy wrote each other several times a day, long, personal emails. Then they agreed to meet in person at a coffee shop on Valentine's Day.
互联网的美丽新世界是什么？你可以结识一个陌生人，在网上比在任何其他地方都更快地亲密接触。但有一周的时间，玛丽和这个家伙每天互发几封很长的私人电子邮件。然后他们约定在情人节那天在一家咖啡馆见面。
I was nervous before we met, because I was worried that he wouldn't find me as interesting in real life. So we met for coffee. We ended up spending the next 12 hours together.
见面之前我很紧张，因为我担心他在现实生活中不会觉得我很有趣。所以我们见了咖啡。最终我们在一起度过了接下来的12个小时。
There wasn't really a turning point until a few days later. We had continued to see each other. And one night, we ended up going out to his office at Microsoft. It was about midnight and nobody was there. And we were hanging out, and one thing led to another. And all of a sudden, we were making out.
直到几天后才有一个转折点。我们继续见面。一天晚上，我们最终去了他在微软的办公室。大约是午夜，那里没人。我们在那闲逛，事情自然而然就发生了。突然间，我们就在亲热了。
And?
然后呢？
It was crazy.
太疯狂了。
And you were glad, though, because you were liking him.
不过你很高兴，因为你喜欢他。
Oh yeah, yeah. It wasn't a bad thing. But it was awkward because it was my first time. I had never really done that with anybody before.
哦，是的，是的。那不是坏事。但那很尴尬，因为那是我的第一次。我以前从未和任何人那样做过。
It was your very first time actually having sex with somebody?
那是你真正和别人发生性关系的第一次？
Right, well, no. It was my first time kissing anybody.
对，嗯，不是。那是我第一次亲吻任何人。
Kissing anybody at all?
亲吻任何人？
Yeah.
是的。
Because you hadn't had a high school boyfriend who you would do that with?
因为你以前没有高中男朋友和你做过那个？
No. No. I was a real big loner in high school. I didn't get out much.
没有。没有。我在高中是个很大的独行侠。我不怎么出门。
So it was your first time just making out with somebody and it was at Microsoft.
所以这是你第一次和别人亲热，而且是在微软。
Yeah. And so it made it all the more surreal, I think. It was just weird for me to think that, here's this guy I met a little over a week ago by chance on the internet. And here we are at his office doing this.
是的。所以我认为这让一切显得更加超现实。想到这里，这个家伙是我一周多前偶然在互联网上认识的，而现在我们在这里做这件事，对我来说太奇怪了。
And then after that, I barely heard from him. He told me that he didn't want a relationship right now, that he wanted to wait. He kept using the term, he wanted to make his first million before he had a relationship with somebody.
然后在那之后，我几乎没再收到他的消息。他告诉我，他现在不想建立恋爱关系，他想等等。他一直用这个词，他想在和别人建立恋爱关系之前赚到他的第一个一百万。
His first million?
他的第一个一百万？
Yes. After the fact, after the night at his office down there at Microsoft, I noticed, boy, he really was feeding me some lines there.
是的。事后，在微软办公室那个晚上之后，我注意到，天哪，他真的在那儿对我撒谎。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like what else?
比如还有什么？
He actually was going to set me up with a copy of Office 97. He never did.
他实际上打算给我装一份Office 97。他从来没做。
The cad! At what point in the whole interaction did he promise you the Office 97, the free software?
这家伙！他在整个互动的哪一刻承诺给你Office 97，那款免费软件？
Actually, the first night we met.
其实，我们见面第一晚就说了。
Did you just think, he's feeding me a lot of soup?
你当时就觉得，他在对你灌输很多汤？
No. I thought it was cool, because I had heard some things about Office 97. Wow, I'd like to have that.
不。我觉得这很酷，因为我听说过一些关于Office 97的事。哇，我很想要那个。
Now I'm sure you can only look back on the incredible naivety. Some young man is prowling the streets of Seattle, walking through the U District, telling women--
现在我确信你只能回顾当时难以置信的幼稚。某个年轻人正在西雅图街头徘徊，穿过大学区，告诉女人们——
Got your free software.
拿着你的免费软件。
People came to the Museum of Contemporary Art with their own stories about the internet. My co-host is David Hauptschein.
人们带着他们自己的互联网故事来到当代艺术博物馆。我的联合主持人是大卫·豪普沙因。
We're going to begin with Joe Fosco. In preparation for this show, we spent many hours surfing the net together and finding files that we thought were interesting. And Joe's going to come up and read some. [APPLAUSE]
我们将从乔·福斯科开始。为了准备这个节目，我们花了很多时间一起浏览网页，寻找我们认为有趣的档案。乔会上来朗读一些。（掌声）
Wait a minute, Joe. Let me get this timer going here. I've got to put these other ones in different places.
等一下，乔。让我把这个计时器搞定。我得把其他几个放在不同的地方。
This one I'm going to read now is a website of this guy who's building an aluminum ball, a ball of aluminum foil. And he went into quite a bit of detail about this ball.
我现在要读的这个是一个家伙的网站，他正在建造一个铝球，一个锡箔球。他对这个球的细节描述得非常详细。
He says, "I don't remember exactly how the ball began, but it is a sphere, composed entirely of aluminum foil of various varieties. It is mostly candy wrappers with a few bits of foil and other food items mixed in. So far the best finish coat is York Peppermint Patty wrappers. Other foil is fine, but a coat of Peppermint Patty wrappers is necessary to keep it on.
他说，“我不记得这个球是怎么开始的，但它是一个球体，完全由各种各样的锡箔纸组成。它主要是糖果包装纸，混入了一些锡箔碎片和其他食品包装。到目前为止，最好的涂层是约克薄荷糖包装纸。其他锡箔纸也可以，但必须要有薄荷糖包装纸来保持它。”
Gum wrappers also tend to have that quality, but they are far too difficult to peel, considering the minimal bulk they have. Gum wrappers do make a good finish coat on top of Peppermint Patty wrappers for show. Some items, such as Hershey's Miniatures, which look like they might be good candidates for foil, aren't. The ball is more impressive in person than this page can hope to depict."
口香糖包装纸也倾向于有这种质量，但它们太难剥了，考虑到它们只有很少的体积。口香糖包装纸确实能在薄荷糖包装纸上做出很好的饰面。有些项目，比如好时迷你巧克力，看起来可能是不错的候选人，但其实不是。球体在现实中比这个页面所能描绘的要令人印象深刻得多。”
There's a picture of the ball.
球的照片在那里。
Oh, there is. I don't know if you can see it. [LAUGHTER] And then he has this diary of its growth. And it starts back in January. And he says, "we've gotten an electric postage scale in the office. It reads one more digit of precision, so we now have a weight of 3.9 ounces. I have done the math to compute the density of the ball. Curiously, it is much lower than that of solid aluminum.
哦，确实有。我不知道你们能不能看到。（笑声）然后他有这个生长的日记。它开始于一月份。他说，“办公室里有个电子邮资秤。它能多读一位精度，所以我们现在的重量是3.9盎司。我做了数学计算来计算球的密度。奇怪的是，它比固体铝的密度低得多。”
I have a hard time believing that the ball is less than half aluminum by mass, so I invite you to let me know if there are any errors in my computations. I expected that the density would be less than that of solid aluminum because of a small amount of air between layers of the foil, the adhesive coatings, inks, and small quantities of chocolate grease and other leftovers from the food items that the wrappers were originally used to package. I wouldn't have been too surprised by a 5% or even 10% difference, but I find the actual results obtained a little difficult to believe."
“我很难相信这个球的铝含量按质量计不到一半，所以我邀请你让我知道我的计算是否有任何错误。我预料到密度会低于固体铝，因为箔层之间有少量的空气，粘合剂涂层，墨水，还有少量的巧克力油脂和其他原包装食品留下的残留物。我对5%甚至10%的差异不会感到太惊讶，但我发现实际获得的结果有点难以置信。”
The other interesting thing is that on this, he has links to other sites that are making aluminum foil balls. [LAUGHTER] And someone else who is making a rubber band ball. [APPLAUSE]
另一个有趣的事情是，在这个页面上，他有链接指向其他正在制作锡箔球的网站。（笑声）还有其他人正在制作橡皮筋球。（掌声）
Our next presenter, our next reader, Noel.
下一位演讲者，下一位读者，诺埃尔。
My name is Noel, and I'm diastematic. Anybody here know what that means? It means that I have a gap between my front two teeth. For those of you unfamiliar with this whole website gap-tooth thing, I built a website for gap-tooth people. So yeah, idiotic. You want it? You've got it.
我叫诺埃尔，我有牙缝。这里有人知道那是什么意思吗？这意味着我的门牙之间有缝隙。对于那些不熟悉整个网站牙缝事物的人来说，我为一个牙缝人建立了一个网站。所以是的，很白痴。你想要吗？你有它。
But I'm in good company. 10% of America, including David Letterman, Lauren Hutton, Noam Chomsky, Supreme Court Justice Sandra Day O'Connor, Itzhak Perlman, Chaucer's Wife of Bath, Vince Lombardi, blah, blah, blah, all with the tooth cleavage. I must admit, for better or for worse, yes, I'm the one who built this website. But the emphasis is humor. In early November last year--
但我找到了好伴侣。10%的美国人，包括大卫·莱特曼、劳伦·赫顿、诺姆·乔姆斯基、最高法院大法官桑德拉·戴·奥康纳、伊扎克·帕尔曼、乔叟的巴斯夫人、文斯·隆巴迪，等等等等，都有牙缝。我必须承认，无论好坏，是的，我就是建立这个网站的人。但重点是幽默。去年11月初——
Wait, humor versus what? Like, attacks at people without gaps in their teeth? What would be the other thing that you would do? You would proselytize on behalf-- try to bring people over, encourage people to create gaps in their teeth?
等等，幽默对比什么？比如，攻击那些牙缝没有缝的人？你还会做其他什么事情？你会代表——试图把人拉过来，鼓励人们创造牙缝吗？
Absolutely. This is very, this will hit on a lot of those themes. In early November last year, I was watching a Bears-Packers game. And during the pregame ceremonies, the USPS, the post office, unveiled art for a new stamp, due this summer, featuring the late, great Vince Lombardi, who was one of the greatest gappers ever to live. He was on a stamp, riding high atop the team in the throes of victory, smiling huge. But something was missing, Coach Lombardi's trademark gap-toothed grin. He had near-perfect pearly whites and the gap was gone.
绝对。这会击中很多这些主题。去年11月初，我在看一场熊队和包装工队的比赛。在赛前仪式上，美国邮政局揭幕了一枚新邮票的艺术，定于今年夏天，以已故伟大的文斯·隆巴迪为特色，他是有史以来最伟大的牙缝人之一。他在邮票上，骑在胜利的高处，笑得很灿烂。但少了些什么，隆巴迪教练标志性的牙缝笑容。他有近乎完美的珍珠般的白牙，缝隙不见了。
The next day, as a joke, I added a page to the gap-tooth website, protesting the post office's depiction of Lombardi as a cosmetically-altered hero. Who would Don King be if he were bald? Or Gorbachev without the Kool-Aid stain? Or Jimmy Durante without that nose?
第二天，作为开玩笑，我在牙缝网站上增加了一个页面，抗议邮局对隆巴迪作为美容改变英雄的描绘。如果唐·金秃头了，那他会是谁？或者戈尔巴乔夫没有了那个红酒渍？或者吉米·杜兰特没有了那个鼻子？
So knowing that this was the web, the oddball media that gets no real merit for its content, I expected little to no attention. But then came Yahoo, which featured it as a weekly pick. The Washington Post had me on the phone and ran a half-page story with my before and after pics. Chicago's Channel 7 came to my apartment and ran a story on its 6:00 News, just before the Super Bowl.
所以知道这是网络，那种内容没有真正价值的怪异媒体，我预料到很少甚至没有注意。但后来雅虎出现了，将其作为每周精选。华盛顿邮报给我打电话，刊登了半页关于我的前后对比照的故事。芝加哥第7频道来到我的公寓，在超级碗之前的6点新闻里报道了一个故事。
Getting out of hand? Yeah, timeout! If you're thinking this pathetic web-based protest should never have received any attention, I'm in agreement with you. What was ironic about this story is that they painted me as a freak-- imagine that-- a super fan ready to strap myself with bombs and blow up my teeth and Washington, DC if they didn't change the art.
失控了吗？是的，暂停！如果你认为这个可悲的网络抗议不应该得到任何注意，我和你意见一致。这个故事讽刺的是，他们把我描述成一个怪胎——想象一下——一个随时准备穿上炸弹并炸掉我的牙齿和华盛顿特区的超级粉丝，如果他们不改变艺术的话。
And I thought, I'm just running a website for gap-toothed people. You can't take me that seriously. So I called up Bob, the artist of the postage stamp, and we talked about the stamp. We discussed angles and art representation. He was a really nice guy. I was thinking about dropping the protest already when he told me his three-year-old daughter was gap-toothed.
我想，我只是在经营一个为牙缝人服务的网站。你不能这么认真地对待我。所以我给邮票的艺术家鲍勃打了电话，我们讨论了邮票。我们讨论了角度和艺术表现。他真是个好人。当他告诉我他三岁的女儿有牙缝时，我就已经在考虑放弃抗议了。
And that was it. Protest over. But what still gets me today is that the web has the power to make insignificant things seem real, that email can really serve as a powerful form of protest, which it did in this case, and that people, including myself, really do have too much time on their hands. [LAUGHTER] [APPLAUSE]
就是这样。抗议结束了。但今天仍然让我困惑的是，网络有能力让无关紧要的事情显得真实，电子邮件真的可以成为一种强大的抗议形式，就像这个案例一样，而且人们，包括我自己，真的有太多时间在手了。（笑声）（掌声）
Well, for our next one, I thought we'd do one that people contacted us when we advertised around the country for things going on on the net. And somebody notified us about this one web page. We were searching for people who were having experiences on the net that they would never have otherwise. And this particular page was made by a woman named Jenni Ringley, a senior at Dickinson College in Pennsylvania. And like a lot of people, she created her own little home page on the world wide web.
好吧，对于下一个，我想做一个我们在全国各地为网上发生的事情做广告时人们联系我们的故事。有人通知我们这个网页。我们正在寻找在网上有其他地方无法发生的经历的人。而这个特定的页面是由宾夕法尼亚州迪金森学院的大四学生珍妮·林利制作的。像很多人一样，她在万维网上创建了自己的小主页。
There's the regular part of my page, I guess you would say, with information about me, the music I like, things like that, like everybody has on their page. The one item that has become extremely popular, though, is the JenniCam. And it's just a camera that sits in my room and takes a picture every three minutes and uploads it. So every three minutes, you can find out what fascinating thing I'm doing in my room.
我想你会说我的页面有常规部分，有关于我的信息，我喜欢的音乐，像那样的东西，就像每个人页面上都有的一样。不过，变得非常流行的一项是珍妮摄像头。它只是一个坐在我房间里的摄像头，每三分钟拍一张照片并上传。所以每三分钟，你就可以发现我在房间里做什么迷人的事情。
The JenniCam is on seven days a week, 24 hours a day, and the number of people who want to see what fascinating thing is going on in a college girl's dorm room each day?
珍妮摄像头每周7天，每天24小时开启，每天想要看一个大学女生的宿舍里正在发生什么迷人事情的人数？
People, I'm not sure. But as far as number of hits go, we get over 500,000 hits a day.
人，我不确定。但就点击量而言，我们每天有超过50万的点击。
A half million hits every single day.
每天50万次点击。
OK, I'm just going to stop the recording right there. This is Ira. This is me in the present. This number right here, this number, a half million hits, we had no way to confirm that at the time. And not only that, we had no idea how to interpret that number. Like, it just seemed absurdly high, the idea that each page hit didn't necessarily represent a distinct person, that thought had not totally penetrated the culture.
好的，我就在这里停止录音。这是艾拉。这是现在的我。就在这里，这个50万次点击的数字，我们当时没有办法确认。不仅如此，我们根本不知道如何解释这个数字。比如，它看起来荒谬地高，认为每个页面点击不一定代表一个不同的人，这种想法还没有完全渗透到文化中。
And if you think about a photo every three minutes on this website, somebody staying on that site an hour might be counted as 20 separate hits. You'd only need 25,000 people to get to a half million. OK, anyway, let's get back.
如果你考虑这个网站上每三分钟一张照片，在一个小时里呆在这个网站上的人可能会被计算为20次单独的点击。你只需要25000人就可以达到50万。好的，不管怎样，让我们回来。
A half million hits every single day. And what do people see?
每天50万次点击。人们看到了什么？
Nothing, really. I write email. I sleep. I have friends over. You can watch my hedgehog when I'm not in the room. Things like that. Pretty much, just regular college life as far as I know.
真的没什么。我写电子邮件。我睡觉。我有朋友过来。当我不在这房间时，你可以看我的刺猬。像这样的事情。差不多，据我所知，只是普通的大学生活。
Our associate producer tuned in to your page just to see what was going on. And for about a half an hour, she witnessed you on the phone. Every three minutes, there'd be another picture of you in a different position on the telephone.
我们的助理制片人调到你的页面只是为了看看发生了什么。大约半小时，她目击你在电话上。每三分钟，就会有另一张你在电话上不同位置的照片。
I talk on the phone a lot.
我经常打电话。
In a way, it's hard to think of anything more banal than seeing a college student's dorm room.
从某种程度上讲，很难想到比看一个大学生的宿舍更平庸的事情。
I would have to agree. I would absolutely agree. I don't do anything that's that interesting. I don't have company very often. I don't do anything more interesting really than talk on the phone, watch TV, and sleep.
我必须同意。我绝对同意。我不做任何特别有趣的事情。我很少有客人在。除了打电话、看电视和睡觉，我真的不做任何更有趣的事情。
Let me ask you to talk about the nudity.
让我请你谈谈裸露。
Well, whenever I'm nude in my room, I'm nude on the JenniCam.
嗯，无论我什么时候在房间里裸体，我在珍妮摄像机上就是裸体的。
But when I think about how often somebody is nude in the course of a day, it's really not very long.
但当我想到一个人一天里裸体的时间有多长时，真的不是很久。
Well, maybe I'm not an average person. But I figure when I'm alone, who really cares? I sleep naked, and I get changed. And when I get out of the shower, I'm all wet. There's no hurry to put on clothes.
嗯，也许我不是一个普通人。但我认为当我一个人时，谁真正在乎呢？我裸睡，我换衣服。当我洗完澡出来时，我全身都湿了。没急着穿衣服。
Explain what the thrill is about being naked in front of a computer camera.
解释一下在电脑摄像头前裸体的快感是什么。
Actually, with the camera there, I don't think about it much. So whenever I'm normally naked in my room, that's when I would be on the camera. It really doesn't affect me in much of a big way, I would say.
其实，摄像头在那，我没怎么想它。所以无论我什么时候在房间里正常裸体，那都是我会出现在摄像头上的时候。我想说，它真的没有以大的方式影响我。
But wait, you're saying it means nothing to you?
但等等，你是说它对你没有任何意义？
I think the camera would be a lot less interesting if I paid that much attention to it. It would be more of a staged show, and you can go see a staged show anywhere. I think the whole appeal of the camera is that it is whatever is normally going on in my room. And with it having been up for a year and a half now, I'm pretty accustomed to it being there. It really doesn't affect me much, I would say.
我想如果我那么注意它，摄像头会少有趣得多。它会更像一场精心策划的表演，你可以在任何地方看到一场策划的表演。我想摄像头的全部吸引力在于它就是我房间里正常发生的事情。随着它已经开启了一年半，我已经很习惯它在那里了。我想说，它真的没怎么影响我。
Have there been any moments over the last two years where you were sort of sorry that the camera was in the dorm room?
这两年里有什么时刻你有点后悔摄像头在宿舍里吗？
Actually, it goes sort of the opposite way. Whenever I go home for breaks, for spring break or something like that, I'm always sad to be away from the camera. It's really a different feeling, whenever I'm in the room and the camera is broken, or for some reason, my room feels totally different. It's like I'm completely alone. So I usually prefer the camera be there, and I'm sad when it's off as opposed to wishing it weren't there.
其实，它是反过来的。无论什么时候我回家度假，为了春假或类似的，我总是很伤心远离摄像头。无论我什么时候在房间里，摄像头坏了，或者由于某种原因，我的房间感觉完全不同，感觉真的完全不同。就像我完全一个人。所以我通常更喜欢摄像头在那里，当它关闭时我很伤心，而不是希望它不在那里。
Because you don't feel alone when it's on.
因为当它开启时你不觉得孤单。
Right. Even though there's nobody actually there with me, even though I'm still alone, even if there's nobody watching the camera from the other end, it's just comforting to know that there is somebody metaphorically out there.
对。即使实际上没有人和我在一起，即使我仍然是一个人，即使另一端没有人看着摄像头，知道在隐喻的层面上外面有人在，这很安慰人。
In your view, why are so many people checking out the site each day?
在你看来，为什么每天有那么多人检查这个网站？
A lot of the people, it's totally hoping to find me getting out of the shower, getting dressed for bed, things like that. It's hoping to find the nudity. But I get lots of email from people who say that it's just nice when they're alone in their office to know that there's somebody else out there, somebody else that is doing nothing more interesting than what they're doing at the same time. It's like having a little virtual friend.
很多这些人，完全是希望发现我洗完澡出来，穿睡衣，像那样的事情。它是希望发现裸露。但我收到很多来自人们的电子邮件，说当他们独自在办公室时，知道外面还有一个人，有人做的事情不比他们同时在做的事情有趣，这很好。这就像有一个小小的虚拟朋友。
Now, at some point in the two years, you've probably had somebody over in the dorm room to mess around.
现在，在这两年里的某个时刻，你可能有客人到宿舍里搞乱。
Sure.
当然。
And?
然后呢？
At that point, it goes on the other person's comfortability. I have no problem doing that. And that's the whole point of the camera is that it's whatever I'm doing. When I went into this, I understood that, in order to make it really work, it would have to be no matter what I was doing. But I can't really enforce that on people who are visiting me. So if the other person is uncomfortable, then the camera is turned off, or it points to a different part of the room.
在这一点上，它取决于另一个人的舒适度。我不介意做那个。摄像头的全部意义在于它是我正在做的任何事情。当我进入这个时，我明白，为了让它真正工作，它必须是无论我正在做什么。但我不能真正强迫在访问我的人身上。所以如果另一个人不舒服，那么摄像头被关闭，或者它指向房间的不同部分。
And generally, has the other person been uncomfortable?
总的来说，另一个人不舒服吗？
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
Was there ever a time that you actually had somebody over where you actually kept the camera on the two of you?
有没有什么时候你真正有客人在，你实际上把摄像头保持在你们两个身上？
Yes, in fact. And the funny thing is that it never actually was broadcast because the number of people suddenly reloading on the server ended up crashing the computer that posted the JenniCam at the time.
是的，其实。有趣的事情是它从来没有真正播出，因为服务器上突然重载的人数最终搞垮了当时发布珍妮摄像头的电脑。
Wow.
哇。
So even though we were there and the camera was on, the server was crashed by the number of people wanting to see.
所以即使我们在那里，摄像头开着，服务器也被想要观看的人数搞垮了。
What's your impression of who these people are?
你对这些人是谁有什么印象？
Oh, I don't know. Mostly men, it's almost exclusively men. I get about 700 emails a day. And of that number, maybe 10 are from women.
哦，我不知道。大部分是男人，几乎全是男人。我每天收到大约700封电子邮件。在这个数字中，也许10封来自女性。
You get 700 emails a day?
你每天收到700封电子邮件？
Right.
对。
What are people saying to you?
人们在对你说什么？
Well, a lot of those are entries to a contest on my web page called "Name that Curve" where once a week I put up a new picture of some close-up shot of a part of my body and people guess what it is. So I would say 300 or so of that number are "Name that Curve" entries. The rest of them are people saying either I saw your web page, I like your page, or can I call you, or can you send me private, special pictures? It really, really, ranges.
嗯，其中很多是参加我网页上一个叫“命名曲线”的竞赛的条目，每周我都会放上一张我身体某部分的特写照片，人们猜测那是什么。所以我认为这个数字中的300左右是“命名曲线”条目。其余的是人们说我看过你的网页，我喜欢你的页面，或者我可以给你打电话吗，或者你能寄给我私人的、特别的照片吗？它真的，真的，范围很广。
Jenny says she spends five to six hours a day answering email. And when I talked to her, on the one hand, there seemed to be something completely innocent in what she was doing, putting herself out there and not really caring who sees. And if you press her about her on exhibitionism, she'll tell you over and over, oh, no, no, it's not about exhibitionism. It's an experiment at letting people view a person's entire life without editing.
珍妮说她每天花五到六个小时回答电子邮件。当我谈到她时，一方面，她在做的事情里似乎有一些完全无辜的东西，把自己放出来，并不真正关心谁看。如果你因为她的暴露狂而逼她，她会一遍又一遍地告诉你，哦，不，不，这不是关于暴露狂。这是一个实验，让人们在不编辑的情况下查看一个人的整个生活。
Though, one thing that she's gotten on the internet that she could never have gotten so easily any other way is she's famous within a small circle. It's a small, particular kind of thing.
虽然，她在互联网上得到的一件她本来无法如此轻易在其他地方得到的事情是，她在一个小圈子里很有名。这是一件小而特别的事情。
I do get a fair number, at this point, of requests for autographed pictures and people wanting to buy my hair and my clothing, things like that.
在这一点上，我确实收到了相当多要求签名照片的请求，人们想要买我的头发和我的衣服，类似的东西。
What?
什么？
It's pretty scary. Well, one time, I was caught on camera actually trimming my bangs, because if you only have to do that, it's cheaper. And all of a sudden, I got 40 emails from people saying, are you going to do anything with that hair? Can I buy it from you?
它很吓人。嗯，有一次，我在摄像头上被抓到其实在修剪我的刘海，因为如果你只需要做那个，它更便宜。突然间，我收到了40封来自人们的电子邮件说，你打算用那头发做什么吗？我可以从你那里买吗？
And what did you make of that?
你对那个做了什么？
Well, it's kind of scary. I mean, I do meet people from time to time. Somebody will say, I'm passing through the area, do you think I could meet you?
嗯，有点吓人。我的意思是我确实不时见人。有人会说，我经过这个地区，你认为我可以见你吗？
And you say?
你说了什么？
I actually have a pretty good knack for getting a good feeling about people right off the bat. So sometimes I say no, sometimes I say yes. I've had dinner with probably a dozen people from the JenniCam.
我其实对第一时间对人有一种很好的感觉。所以有时我说不，有时我说是的。我和大概十二个从珍妮摄像头来的人吃过晚饭。
And has that been nice?
那很好吗？
I had one person who had a hard time taking no for an answer, even after I made it abundantly clear I wasn't interested.
我有一个人很难接受不作为答案，即使在我明确表示我不感兴趣之后。
Really? That's kind of creepy.
真的吗？那有点令人毛骨悚然。
It is, kind of. I've had a fair number of improper passes at the end of the evening. But it stays at a pass.
它有点，是的。在晚上结束时，我收到相当多次不适当的搭讪。但它停留在搭讪。
If there were a cable channel that would just have a camera on in your room, with no sound, 24 hours a day, do you think you'd get a half million viewers?
如果有一个有线频道会在你的房间里一直开着摄像头，没有声音，24小时一天，你认为你会得到50万观众吗？
I don't think so. I don't think I would, because if you have the TV, you have other things you can watch. I think it would still be popular, but I think at that point, it would be a lot less interesting. Because people can do this from their offices, at work, if they have internet usage that's not monitored. From work, you can just put it on and leave it on in the background while you're doing whatever else on your computer.
我不这么认为。我不认为我会，因为如果你有电视，你有其他可以看的东西。我认为它仍然会很受欢迎，但我认为在这一点上，它会少有趣得多。因为人们可以在他们的办公室做这个，在工作时，如果他们有不受监控的互联网使用。从工作处，你可以只是把它打开并让它在后台开着，同时你在电脑上做其他任何事情。
Jenni Ringley has just graduated from college. She's moved to another city, where she has gotten a job designing web pages for a big national magazine. [APPLAUSE]
珍妮·林利刚刚大学毕业。她搬到了另一个城市，在那里她得到了一份为一家大型国家杂志设计网页的工作。（掌声）
OK. It's me again in the present. Jenni Ringley and the JenniCam were internet celebrities for seven years, written about all the time. There were parody websites, JenniCam-ing people's pets and stuff like that. She was invited on the Letterman show. She was included in a 2001 exhibit done by the Museum of Modern Art. The word JenniCam was reportedly, for a while, one of the most popular search terms on Slashdot.
好的。又是现在的我。珍妮·林利和珍妮摄像头做了七年的互联网名流，一直被写到。有恶搞网站，珍妮摄像头搞人们的宠物之类的东西。她被邀请上莱特曼秀。她被包括在现代艺术博物馆2001年的展览中。据报道，珍妮摄像头这个词有一段时间是Slashdot上最流行的搜索词之一。
Until finally, at the end of 2003, Jenni Ringley shut down the site. According to Wikipedia, fans started to turn on her in part because they were annoyed that she just would loaf around the apartment. There was a feeling of, like, get a job. By the end, people had to pay to log on to the site, and she actually was making decent money from it, or seemed to. And this annoyed fans as well.
直到最后，在2003年底，珍妮·林利关闭了网站。据维基百科，粉丝开始背离她，部分是因为他们很恼火她只是在公寓里游手好闲。有一种想法，比如，找份工作。到最后，人们必须付费登录网站，她实际上从中赚了不错的钱，或者看起来是这样。这也惹恼了粉丝。
To the very end, she continued to describe the site as a kind of art project. "I keep JenniCam alive not because I want or need to be watched, but because I simply don't mind being watched," she wrote. "What you see is my life, exactly as it would be, whether or not there were cameras watching, as a chronicle, a long-term experiment."
直到最后，她继续将该网站描述为一种艺术项目。“我保持珍妮摄像头活跃不是因为我想要或需要被观看，而是因为我根本不介意被观看，”她写道。“你看到的是我的生活，正如它将会是的那样，无论是否有摄像头在观看，作为一种编年史，一个长期的实验。”
Well, now, this example of people's lives changed by the internet, Eileen and Fred Kiefer live outside Columbus, Ohio. They are septuagenarians with seven kids and 13 grandkids.
好吧，现在，这个互联网改变人们生活的例子，艾琳和弗雷德·基弗住在俄亥俄州哥伦布市外。他们是七个孩子和13个孙辈的七旬老人。
OK, well, when we first got our email going on our computer, I sent a message to our son in Milwaukee whose address was K-I-E-F-F.
好的，当我们第一次在电脑上搞定电子邮件时，我给我儿子发了一条信息，他在密尔沃基，他的地址是K-I-E-F-F。
K-I-E-F-F?
K-I-E-F-F？
Yeah. It was my first time to use it, and I left one of the F's off.
对。这是我第一次使用它，我漏掉了一个F。
Her email was a chatty email about everything going on in the family, signed "love, Mom."
她的电子邮件是一封关于家庭中发生的一切的聊天邮件，签名为“爱你的，妈妈”。
So I got back a letter from someone whose address was K-I-E-F. And he said, I enjoyed this letter, but I don't think you meant it for me. And so then I wrote back and said, thanks and explained how I'd made the mistake. And he wrote back. And we've been writing now for, it'll be two years this month.
所以我收到了一个人的回信，他的地址是K-I-E-F。他说，我喜欢这封信，但我不认为你是写给我的。所以我就回信说，谢谢并解释了我怎么犯的错误。他又回信了。我们现在已经写了，这个月就是两年了。
The man, the couple actually, who got her email were Kiefer and Galen Mitchell in Portland, Oregon. He works at Tandy and does a radio show out there. And when he got Mrs. Kiefer's email in his account, the thing that actually got to him was that she signed it "love, Mom." His own mother had just died two months before. His father had been dead for years. Mrs. Kiefer said she never intended or wanted to have a long-term email friendship.
收到她邮件的男人，这对夫妇，是俄勒冈州波特兰市的基弗和盖伦·米切尔。他在Tandy工作，并在那里做电台节目。当他在他的账户收到基弗夫人的电子邮件时，实际上击中他的是她签名为“爱你的，妈妈”。他自己的母亲刚在两个月前去世。他的父亲几年前就去世了。基弗夫人说她从来没有打算或想要有一个长期的电子邮件友谊。
It seems like we had nothing in common going in. The age difference, and they had no children, and they're Mormons and we're Catholics. So it seemed like there wasn't a whole lot that we had to talk about. But we never have any trouble.
看起来我们在进入时没有任何共同点。年龄差距，他们没有孩子，他们是摩门教徒，我们是天主教徒。所以看起来我们没什么可谈的。但我们从来没有困难。
At first, we were writing every day. We were both so excited about this. And now, we're usually in touch at least once a week. And we've visited, and he's in Oregon. We're in Ohio. We visited in Portland last year and spent a couple days with him and had a wonderful time.
起初，我们每天都在写。我们都对这个很兴奋。现在，我们通常至少每周联系一次。而且我们访问过，他在俄勒冈州。我们在俄亥俄州。我们去年在波特兰访问过，和他一起度过了几天，度过了一段美好的时光。
And they're like 30 years younger than we are. So we've become mom and dad, and we've adopted them. We call them our legally adopted children. And in December, when I had a serious operation, he was on the phone every night, just like the rest of our kids. So he's really become one of our kids.
他们比我们年轻30岁左右。所以我们成为了妈妈和爸爸，我们收养了他们。我们称他们为我们法律上收养的孩子。而在12月，当我做了严重的手术时，他每晚都在电话上，就像我们其余的孩子一样。所以他真的成为了我们孩子之一。
So what in the world was it in those first emails they sent two years ago? What could people possibly say to create a bond like that?
那么，在那两年前他们发送的第一批电子邮件里到底是什么？人们可能说什么来创造那样的纽带？
Oh, I don't remember. I just remember indicating that I was 70. So there was-- I didn't want anybody to think that we were going to have this big romance or anything.
哦，我不记得了。我只记得我指出我是70岁。所以有——我不想让任何人认为我们将要有一场大的浪漫之类的。
And then--
然后——
Because you read these stories about people doing weird things with people on the internet. We never had that problem.
因为你读过这些关于人们在互联网上与人做奇怪事情的故事。我们从来没有那个问题。
We have seven children. And all of them have email except one. And the ones out of town, we hear from a couple times a week. One of our daughters, we hear from almost daily.
我们有七个孩子。他们除了一个以外都有电子邮件。住在城外的那些，我们每周听到几次。我们的一个女儿，我们几乎每天都听到。
Now, did you have as much contact with them before email?
现在，在电子邮件之前，你和他们有那么多的联系吗？
Oh, no. No. We would talk on the phone maybe once a month. And it was always, how are you? And you never really were part of their lives that way. And two of our children live in Boston. And we just weren't-- well, we were always close. We weren't communicating very often.
哦，不。不。我们也许一个月打一次电话。总是，你怎么样？你从来没有真正那样成为他们生活的一部分。我们的两个孩子住在波士顿。我们只是没有——嗯，我们一直很亲近。我们没有经常交流。
So email has really brought you all closer together.
所以电子邮件真的让你们所有人更亲近了。
Oh, it's wonderful. I keep trying to talk everybody I know into it, if their children have access to a computer. It's changed our life a lot. It's just changed our lives. I wouldn't think of not checking the computer first thing in the morning to see who's writing.
哦，太棒了。我一直尝试说服所有我认识的人使用它，如果他们的孩子有电脑使用权的话。它极大地改变了我们的生活。它只是改变了我们的生活。我不会想到早上第一件事不检查电脑看看是谁在写信。
Eileen Kiefer in Dublin, Ohio.
艾琳·基弗在俄亥俄州都柏林。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Well, as we looked for stories from the net for this show, especially stories of things happened on the net that might not happen anywhere else, we found Earl Jackson. He's an Associate Professor of Comparative Literature at the University of California at Santa Cruz, and he spends a lot of time on the net. He writes about the net, has seven websites himself. And he tells this story, which begins on America Online.
好吧，当我们寻找关于这个节目的网络故事时，特别是网上发生的可能不会在其他任何地方发生的事情的故事，我们发现了厄尔·杰克逊。他是加州大学圣克鲁兹分校的比较文学副教授，他花很多时间在网上。他写关于网络，自己有七个网站。他讲了这个故事，它始于美国在线。
I was on AOL and other services in San Francisco a lot. And there are these chat rooms where gay men can meet and talk. And in San Francisco, it's fairly wild. There's a 24-hour bulletin board that I was observing for this study I was doing, where you could almost be guaranteed that if you lived in San Francisco and you had a modem, you could have sex any time of the day or night. This was a very goal-directed bulletin board.
我在旧金山有很多AOL和其他服务。这里有同性恋男人可以见面和交谈的聊天室。在旧金山，它相当狂野。有一个24小时公告板，我为我正在做的这项研究观察过，在那里你几乎可以保证，如果你住在旧金山，并且你有一个调制解调器，你可以一天或晚上的任何时间做爱。这是一个目标明确的公告板。
Right. People would meet, go have sex.
对。人们见面，去做爱。
Right. And you would know exactly what they wanted to do, and you would probably have nude pictures of them before that. What I also thought was really interesting-- and this  was more true of AOL-- that there was a new metaphysics of sexuality. Because people would talk about, cyber-sex or real sex? And it occurred to me after I listened to enough, by real sex they meant phone sex.
对。而且你会确切地知道他们想做什么，并且你可能在那之前就有他们的裸体照片。我也认为非常有趣的是——这在AOL中更真实——有一种关于性的新形而上学。因为人们会谈论，网络性还是真实性？我在听够了之后意识到，他们所指的真实性是电话性。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah, so it became, instead of a two-tier system, it's a three-tier system. And you have real sex, ultra-real sex, and cyber-sex.
是啊，所以它变成了，而不是一个双层系统，它是一个三层系统。你有真实性，超真实性，和网络性。
Wait, ultra-real sex, you said?
等等，超真实性，你说？
That would mean what I call a slow-time interface, which means actual physical contact.
那将意味着我称之为慢时间接口，这意味着实际的物理接触。
God, do people still do that?
上帝，人们还在做那个吗？
Um, yes.
嗯，是的。
Earl Jackson says that he meets more and more people who have hooked up what amounts to video cameras on their computers with a technology called CU-SeeMe, they can look at the person they're interacting with over the net.
厄尔·杰克逊说他见到越来越多的人，他们把相当于视频摄像机的东西接在他们的电脑上，使用一种叫CU-SeeMe的技术，他们可以看到他们在网上互动的人。
I know people that actually leave physical dates to go home and have sex over the net with the quick cam.
我知道有人实际上离开物理约会，回家通过快速摄像头在网上做爱。
Come
来
It's true. There's an entire culture that's entirely video transmission sexuality now.
这是真的。现在有一种完全是视频传输性的文化。
Talk a little more about that. You actually know somebody who actually left an actual date--
多谈一点那个。你实际上认识某人，他实际上离开了一个实际的约会——
Yeah, me, in fact.
是啊，事实上是我。
Oh, they left you?
哦，他们离开你了？
Yeah, they left me. But he said that that is what he does lately. And I understood that, because a lot of men are afraid of sexual contact because of AIDS. So the perfect thing to eroticize is distance.
是啊，他们离开我了。但他确实说那是他最近做的。我理解了，因为很多男人因为艾滋病而害怕性接触。所以完美的事情是把距离情色化。
And so he says to you-- at what point in the evening did he say, I'm going to go home now?
所以他对你说——他在晚上的什么时刻说，我现在要回家了？
Pretty soon. He said that he really needed to do the CU-SeeMe stuff.
很快。他说他确实需要做CU-SeeMe的东西。
Back in December of 1993, Earl Jackson met a guy over the net in one of these gay chat rooms. The guy's name was Ken, who lived nearby, but he had a boyfriend so the two never met in person. But almost every day for a year, they got online together and created these elaborate fantasies together online, using that kind of software where you can see what the other person types as they type it, and they can see what you type as you type it.
早在1993年12月，厄尔·杰克逊在这些同性恋聊天室之一中通过网络认识了一个家伙。这家伙的名字叫肯，住在附近，但他有一个男朋友，所以两人从来没有亲自见面。但几乎每一天，持续了一年，他们在线聚在一起，通过使用那种可以看到对方打字时打什么，并且他们可以看到你打字时打什么的软件，一起创造了这些复杂的幻想。
We would have a fantasy about what if he came to my classroom and then I took him back into my office. But it was really sort of a game. But these narratives became so intense that we would set times of the day, or he would just check in. And he said, do you have time for a story now? And he would start it, and then I would continue it. And we have all of these stories.
我们有一个幻想，关于如果他来到我的教室会发生什么，然后我把他带回我的办公室。但它真的像是一个游戏。但这些叙事变得如此强烈，以至于我们会设定一天中的时间，或者他只是会签到。他说，你现在有时间讲故事吗？他会开始它，然后我会继续它。我们有所有这些故事。
But as we kept doing this, then a little part of his life would come in. And then there would be a story that would take us somewhere else. And then I'd know a little bit more. And soon the sex part was really an excuse to tell the other stories.
但当我们继续做这个时，然后他生活的一小部分会进来。然后会有一个故事把我们带到其他地方。然后我会知道多一点。很快性部分真的只是讲其他故事的借口。
And sometimes he would be telling this story about his childhood in Missouri. And then it would remind him of a sexual fantasy. And then he'd put me in it. And you couldn't plan to do these things. We became sort of like jazz pianists or something. We'd have these riffs together.
有时他会讲这个关于他在密苏里州的童年的故事。然后它会提醒他一个性幻想。然后他会把我放进去。你不能计划做这些事情。我们变得有点像爵士钢琴家什么的。我们一起有这些即兴片段。
Then one day, he was asking me if I had time to talk to him. And I was just leaving, but I could tell that even the way he was typing was different.
有一天，他问我是否有时间和他说话。我正要离开，但我能看出即使他打字的方式也不同。
You could tell even the way he was typing was different?
你甚至能看出他打字的方式也不同？
Yes, yes.
是啊，是啊。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
People have different habits in their speed, or the way he would respond, or if he didn't put a smiley face after a certain number of words. I just knew there was something really wrong with the way he asked me if I had time.
人们在他们的速度方面有不同的习惯，或者他会回复的方式，或者如果他在一定数量的词语之后没有放一个笑脸。我只是知道他在问我是否有时间时，某种方式确实错了。
And he said, bad news, son. And I think I knew it instantly, what that was. He had tested positive. And he didn't know how to break it to me. And our messages to each other then became a lot more about that and about what happened to him as a child and other things that were fairly tragic and amazing that he was telling anybody, because he was really one of those strong, silent types.
他说，坏消息，儿子。我想我立即知道那是什么。他检测呈阳性。而他不知道如何把它突破给我。我们给彼此的信息那时变得更多关于那个，关于他小时候发生了什么，以及其他相当悲剧和令人惊奇的东西，他在告诉任何人，因为他确实是那种坚强、沉默的类型之一。
Then-- this is when I should have gotten more nervous-- he started saying that he didn't want any of his porn tapes anymore because he associated the porn with him being positive. So he wanted to mail them to me, and he mailed me a box of them. I didn't really want them, but he wanted to do this for me. So there was suddenly a box of porn tapes in my house. And then the following week, there was one too.
然后——这是当我应该变得更紧张的时候——他开始说他不想要任何他的色情磁带了，因为他把色情与他阳性联系起来。所以他想要邮寄给我，他寄给我一盒。我并不真正想要它们，但他想为我做这个。所以突然间我的房子里有一盒色情磁带。然后接下来的一周，也有一盒。
And then just before I got back to San Francisco, I got a message from him, hoping that I was well and hoping I got the tapes. And he said that I'd get another message very soon. Now, he was writing to me almost entirely in capital letters, which scared me. And I didn't know why. But here's the last one. "I have it all boxed up now. I will give it my friend. He will mail it for me like he did before. And it will arrive either Thursday or Friday, via two-day express. I have a letter coming to you to help explain a few things. Thank you for being a friend when I really needed it. Kenneth."
就在我回到旧金山之前，我收到他的一条信息，希望我好，希望我收到磁带。他说我会很快收到另一条信息。现在，他几乎完全用大写字母给我写信，这吓坏我了。我不知道为什么。但这里是最后一条。“我把它全部打包了。我会给它我的朋友。他会为我邮寄它，就像他之前做的那样。它会周四或周五到达，通过两天快递。我有一封信给你来帮助解释一些事情。谢谢你在我确实需要时作为一个朋友。肯尼斯。”
And then three days, nothing. And then there's just one line. "A package should arrive today. 1/19/95. Email me. Cruiser3. Bye. Love, Ken."
然后三天，什么都没有。然后只有一行。“包裹今天应该到达。1/19/95。电邮我。Cruiser3。再见。爱你的，肯。”
And then on the 25th, there was one that looked like it was from Ken. It was his screen name. But then, when I opened it up, it said, "this is a hard note for me to write. Ken left a note to ask me to let you know Ken took his own life on Friday, January 20. He was cremated yesterday, and his ashes will be dropped into the ocean off of San Francisco today. Ken's mental attitude over the last four to six weeks is very hard to describe. He was a basket case to say the least. I will keep his account open for the next day if you have any questions or response, and I will try to answer them for you. Ken's friend, Dave."
然后在25号，有一条看起来是来自肯的。它是他的屏幕名称。但后来，当我打开它时，它说，“这是我很难写的字条。肯留下了一个字条请求我让你知道肯在周五，1月20日自杀了。他昨天被火化了，他的骨灰今天会被撒进旧金山的海洋里。肯在过去四到六周的精神态度很难描述。至少可以说是崩溃了。如果有什么问题或回应，我会保持他的账户开放一天，我会尝试为你回答。肯的朋友，戴夫。”
Did he send you a final note in the last package he sent you?
他在他寄给你的最后包裹里寄给你最后一张字条吗？
Yeah. It was the only time I ever saw his handwriting. And that said similar things. He said, thank you for being a friend when I needed it. And I would always love you.
是啊。这是我唯一一次看到他的笔迹。那上面说类似的事情。他说，谢谢你在我需要时作为一个朋友。我永远会爱你。
It must have been so strange to see a physical manifestation of him after the email.
在电子邮件之后看到他的物理表现一定很奇怪。
It was. And what was really odd was that, when he first sent the first box of tapes, he told me which tape had a scene where the two people are the ones that he imagined us to be. Now, that doesn't mean that he looked like either one of them, but he knew the fantasies that would resonate with us. So even at that point, our fantasies were constantly mediated by some other technology, which is probably hard for you to imagine.
它是。而且真正奇怪的是，当他第一次寄来第一盒磁带时，他告诉我哪一盘磁带有一个场景，其中两个人是他想象我们成为的人。现在，那并不意味着他看起来像他们中的任何一个，但他知道会引起我们共鸣的幻想。所以即使在那个时候，我们的幻想也被其他技术不断调解，这可能是你们很难想象的。
But none of this was cold. There was something so tender about this that I was very moved by this experience.
但这些都不是冷的。关于这个，有一些如此温柔的东西，以至于我被这种经历非常感动。
After he died, did you go through a period of mourning for him?
在他死后，你是否经历过一段为他哀悼的时期？
Yes, I did. Yes.
是的，我有。是的。
What a strange thing to be mourning somebody who you never actually saw.
哀悼一个你从来没有真正见到的人，真是一件奇怪的事情。
Yeah. Although, it's real. You know, when people say, oh, the computers are making us all isolated and it's such a cold world, I've had emotional experiences and long-term friendships that would have never possible otherwise.
是啊。虽然，它是真实的。你知道，当人们说，哦，电脑正在让我们所有人孤立，那是一个如此冷酷的世界，我确实有过情感体验和长期的友谊，这些本来是不可能的。
It's funny because it's almost like the whole thing, it could be a con, an elaborate con.
这很有趣，因为它几乎就像整个事情，它可能是一个骗局，一个复杂的骗局。
He would be such a creep that-- I thought of that, actually. Because it seemed almost like a melodrama from a long time ago. It was really tawdry. And if I wrote a short story, I wouldn't end it this way because it was too hokey.
他会是如此的令人毛骨悚然，以至于——我确实想到了那个，事实上。因为它看起来几乎像很久以前的通俗剧。它真的很俗气。如果我写短篇小说，我不会以这种方式结束它，因为它太陈腐了。
After he died, you know how after somebody you're close to is gone, how when you go back to the places where you used to go with them, you'll think of them inevitably and miss them. After he was gone, when you would get back on your computer, would you sense his loss?
在他死后，你知道在和你亲近的人离开后，当回到你曾经和他们一起去的地方时，你会不可避免地想到他们并想念他们。在他走后，当你回到你的电脑时，你会感到他的损失吗？
Yes. He really felt gone. He really felt gone. When I saw somebody else using his screen name, I mean, to get a stranger with his screen name, that was really, really chilling.
是的。他确实感到走了。他确实感到走了。当我看到别人使用他的屏幕名称时，我的意思，得到一个用他屏幕名称的陌生人，那真的，真的很冷。
Earl Jackson in Santa Cruz.
厄尔·杰克逊在圣克鲁兹。
Well, our program was produced today by Dolores Wilbur, Julie Snyder, and me, with Paul Tough, David Hauptschein, Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Laura Doggett, Seth Lind, Thea Chaloner, and Sativa January. The internet part of today's program was a co-production with Chicago's Museum of Contemporary Art, Peter Taub, curator.
好吧，我们的节目今天由多洛雷斯·威尔伯，朱莉·斯奈德和我制作，保罗·塔夫，大卫·豪普沙因，彼得·克鲁尼，阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克。伊丽莎白·迈斯特经营我们的网站。来自劳拉·道格特，塞思·林德，西娅·查洛纳和萨蒂瓦·詹姆斯的制作帮助。今天节目的互联网部分是与芝加哥当代艺术博物馆，彼得·陶布，馆长的共同制作。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
David Hauptschein's most recent play, The Ballad of Johnny 5 Star , premiered at the Edinburgh Theater Fringe Festival. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our show for absolutely free, or buy CDs of them, or you know you can download today's program at our archives on that famous internet at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed bu Public Radio International .
大卫·豪普沙因的最新剧本，约翰尼5星的民谣，在爱丁堡戏剧边缘节首演。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以绝对免费听我们的节目，或者买它们的CD，或者你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的我们的档案下载今天的节目。这个美国生活由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资金赞助）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Torey Malatia, who insists he doesn't even know what Office 97 is. No matter what anybody says--
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他坚持认为他甚至不知道Office 97是什么。无论任何人说什么——
He actually was going to set me up with a copy of Office 97. He never did.
他实际上打算给我装一份Office 97。他从来没做。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多这个美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。